[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: As a news
publisher, you
know that many readers are using
their smartphones and tablets
to access news.
To be successful
in this space, you
need a strong mobile
strategy, which
starts with building
a high quality app.
We've gathered 10
tips to help you
with the design and
development of a good news app.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
1, develop a native app.
The best apps in the
Android ecosystem all
have one thing in common.
They're developed as native.
They have great in-app
navigation and support native
gestures.
They benefit from the potential
of full material design.
And compared to web view,
the UX is really responsive.
2, run your apps instantly
without installation.
When you build a
native app, you'll
be able to extend
it to run instantly
without requiring
user installation,
using Android Instant Apps.
Android Instant
Apps will let users
access your app via an URL,
even if it isn't installed
on their device, bringing users
into your app more quickly.
You modularize your
app, and Google Play
will download only the parts
that are needed on the fly.
For users, it will be
a seamless experience,
from launching the
app to signing in,
to making a payment.
3, create a simple, yet
targeted, user experience.
An easy to use
app brings readers
to news that interest
them quickly,
with a clear and
straightforward navigation,
users can easily discover
what they want in your app,
and they'll return more often
to check the latest news
or explore stories.
Let readers customize
categories and sections
according to their interests.
4, use material
design principles
to create a sense
of familiarity.
It's important to support
the navigation structure
with simple material
design integrations
that the user will recognize
from other Android apps.
Organize content
into a hierarchy that
matches your reader's
expectations and place
content in a navigation drawer.
Use tabs so readers
can explore one section
and still see what's
available elsewhere,
or use in-page lists to show
related articles or comments.
Utilize a floating action
button to support key features
that matter in your app,
like a sharing action.
5, make it easy for readers
to share your content.
Shared personal
recommendations can
be a successful way of bringing
in new audiences to your app.
Benefit from word of
mouth distribution
by adding an easy share action
to content so readers can share
with friends, family,
and colleagues,
and set up deep linking so the
share directs the recipient
to the content within your app.
The desire to find
content to share
drives readers to explore
more detailed content,
increasing reader engagement.
6, make some content
available offline.
Newspapers are often
read on trains, subways,
and airplanes, places with
little to no data connection.
Implementing a cache
for offline reading
helps make content
available in these places.
You can also provide
a read later option
to cache selected pages.
If you want to reach
your readers whenever
they want to consume
your content,
then offering this
service is crucial.
7, re-engage your readers
with rich notifications.
Think of Android
notifications as extensions
of your apps interface.
They're a way for
readers to navigate back
to your app, even when
they're not using it.
Offer readers notifications
for breaking news, as well
as personalized notifications
for news that interests them.
Take advantage of
rich notifications
to bring stories to
life with images.
Give readers control
over the amount
of notifications they receive.
Make it possible to turn them
off and use the topics feature,
a Firebase Cloud Messaging to
send notifications in bulk.
8, optimize your
app for tablets.
Tablets now play a huge
part in news consumption.
Users read longer articles
and view more videos
and image galleries on tablet.
By optimizing for
tablet users, you're
likely to get more
engaged readers who
consume more content.
Consider content that makes
use of a tablets' bigger screen
size, and ensure all
fonts are adjusted,
and the text is legible.
Use compound views and
multi-pane layout UIs
to organize content so it's
easier for readers to view.
9, request readers
permissions at runtime.
Avoid asking the
user for permissions
by designing your app so it
simply doesn't need them.
If you can't avoid
using them, at least
make sure no unnecessary
permissions are requested.
Beginning in Android 6.0,
users grab permissions to apps,
while the app is running,
not when they install it.
Help your readers understand
why your app needs a permission
by providing an
explanation when needed.
For example, if you want to
provide local news to readers
in a specific area, ask
their location permission
in that context so they'll
understand the benefit.
Keep in mind that you don't
want to overwhelm your users
with too many explanations.
That might push them
to remove your app.
10, onboard your
readers effectively.
Implement an onboarding
flow for new readers
and for all readers when
you introduce a new feature.
By providing a tutorial
when your app starts,
readers can gain an appreciation
of its features faster.
Keep the tutorial short.
Once it's over, give
readers the option
to customize the app settings,
like notifications or home
screen options.
Let the reader skip
the onboarding flow,
but give the option to watch the
tutorial on demand at any time.
Head over to Google
Play Developer
Console to start taking
advantage of these features.
If you want more tips on how
to improve your news apps
and build a better
mobile business,
check out the other
videos in this series
and download the News
Publisher's Playbook.